bring you some breaking in years now and
we have just had the latest figures from
the Department of Health on kovat 19
deaths and what they tell us is that
fourteen thousand five hundred and
seventy-six people have now died in
hospital after testing positive for
corona virus on yesterday that's 847
more people who have lost their lives
since yesterday's figures well our
correspondent Allie focus group is in
the newsroom for us Allie it's important
isn't it to reflect more than 14 and a
half thousand people in the UK have now
lost their lives in hospital due to this
disease and the number of people losing
their lives in hospital remains daily
above 800 yes that's right you know I
think there's a danger that we get into
the routine of reading you these numbers
every day behind every one of these
statistics is a real life we are still
talking about hundreds of people dying
every single day just to give you those
figures again that we have had in the
last few moments from the Department for
Health 847 more deaths recorded that is
less than yesterday yesterday the
increase was 861 that brings the UK
total to 1400 576 or 14,000 576 we've
also got some of the figures from the
individual nations Northern Ireland have
recorded 18 more deaths bringing their
total to 176 that is the same number
they recorded yesterday Wales 11 more
deaths bringing their total number to
506 that is that is less than they
recorded yesterday yesterday they
recorded 32 deaths Scotland 58 more
deaths which again is less than the
increase they recorded yesterday
bringing their total to 837 now it is
hard to draw any real long-term
conclusions from these daily figures
numbers go up and down what we're trying
to look at are the longer-term trends
having said that I think a tiny
kolima of hope perhaps in the fact that
these figures by and large seem to have
at least been the same and gone down
since yesterday and that is consistent
with the longer term pattern that we are
seeing we are seeing the rate starting
to slow at the beginning of this month
end of last month the numbers of deaths
were doubling every three days that has
now slowed we are starting to see that
peak what looks like that peak
flattening which will perhaps give a
glimmer of hope but as I say we are
still talking about hundreds of deaths
every single day